I asked a question saying why do they
constantly blame capitalism and
socialism is what is the benefit of
doing that what wipe wipe blame an
economical system that's that's proven
that's worth to constantly say black you
know capitalism is getting a black guy
capitalism is getting a black guy
capitalism doesn't work we need a new
form of capitalism how much of that
argument is right and how much of it is
just you know finding something to blame
we don't need a new form of capitalism
we need to go back to capitalism the
type of capitalism that we've been
practicing has been the problem because
it's capitalism in name only
right it's socialism or maybe more
accurately fascism if you understand the
true meaning because fascism is a form
of socialism so it's a communism and
what we've been doing is more of a
mussolini type fascism obviously than
communism but that is the problem with
the economy that economic system but a
in order to do the right thing first you
have to have the politicians and the
central bankers admit that they did the
wrong thing in the past which they never
want to do they never want to fess up to
their mistakes and say we did this right
we interfered with capitalism and that's
why we have this problem so number one
they never want to do that but if they
finally embrace capitalism and say okay
we're gonna swallow this bitter tasting
medicine because ultimately recessions
is the free markets way of fixing the
mistakes that the government and the
central banks create because the
mistakes are made during the bubble
during the boom right everybody feels
great during the boom but that's when
all the MAL investments are made all the
misc allocations or resources are occur
then when there's a bust that's the free
markets attempt to restore order to
create balance in the economy so it's
viable and sustainable and so you have
to allow a recession to run its course
even though it's painful even though it
means people lose jobs investors lose
money
you know loans go into default companies
that are not viable go bankrupt and what
happens in that cleansing process
is that resources are freed up to be
reallocated more efficiently and more
productively that includes labor and
capital and land but that process
obviously is painful to certain people
and you know in the immediate you don't
know how it's gonna end
and so the politicians are under
tremendous pressure to do something
about it oh people are unemployed let's
provide them with money businesses are
gonna fail let's bail them out instead
of doing the right thing by allowing the
businesses to fail right and allowing
all the you know the the reallocation of
labour and capital they interfere but
the interference is what makes it worse
it exacerbates the debt the downturn and
it means it means that we don't get a
real recovery the recovery that we had
following the 2008 financial crisis was
phony
it was just a bigger bubble than the one
that popped had we done the right thing
in a way and let a real estate prices
continue to fall let foreclosures happen
let banks fail and not bail them out let
the bad actors be punished right let new
owners step up and buy in bankruptcy a
lot of these companies that were so
mismanaged and allowed you know
consumption to come down and savings to
go up which is the underlying problem
that the Fed created is a nation where
we have too much debt and not enough
savings so instead of allowing the
savings to be rebuilt and balance sheets
to be improved we inflated an even
bigger bubble than the one that popped
and so we didn't have a real recovery
and that's why the economy is so
vulnerable now to this copán 19 crisis
because as I said the economy was sick
long before the virus infected it and
the air was already coming out of the
bubble because the Fed tried to do
something that was impossible which was
normalized interest rates with an
abnormal amount of debt they got
everybody you know hooked on the the
drug of cheap money and then tried to
withdraw the drug from the market and
there obviously we
with draw at the end of 2018 that's when
the Fed came back and said okay more QE
we're going back to QE
we're going back to rate cuts but then
we got the coronavirus and what
everybody is focusing on is the virus
the virus is the pin the problem is the
massive bubble that that pin pricked and
in fact I said it was already kind of
pricked that pin just put a gaping hole
in that bubble and now the air is coming
gushing out but the reason that the
economy is so vulnerable is because
we're broke and levered to the health
the reason that nobody can do without
income for a few weeks or a few months
is because everybody has debt to service
right corporations are levered to the
max they've been borrowing all this
cheap money from the Fed they've been
using it to buy up their overpriced
stock so they didn't have any any any
savings individual households are
leveraged to the max on cheap consumer
credit they got mortgage debt student
loans auto loans credit card debt
they're living paycheck to paycheck
you take that paycheck to pay they can't
pay their rent they can't pay their
mortgage they can't pay their debts the
same thing with local governments estate
municipalities have been you know making
promises they couldn't keep and been
borrowing all this money they have
underfunded pensions they got nothing
saved for a rainy day then it pours so
the states are broke and then the
federal government of course is we've
been running massive deficits even when
the economy was supposedly recovering so
everybody is broke nobody has savings
and then this crisis comes right and and
a lot of people want to talk about well
this is like world war two it's the
opposite of world war two because when
world war two hit nobody got bailed out
nobody got a stimulus check every got
everybody got a bill for World War two
first of all sixteen million men had a
fight they had to leave their homes and
had to go to Europe and Japan but the
people who didn't fight had to finance
the war the government massively
increased taxes when the war began Oh
fewer than 3% of the poppy
even paid income taxes before World War
two once it started
better than 30% of the people started to
pay income taxes because we imposed
withholding taxes for the first time as
part of the victory tax but not only did
we triple taxes on the middle class to
pay for the war but the government
borrowed money directly from the minimal
middle class by selling war bonds and so
everybody stopped spending and was
giving all their money to the government
in either taxes or indirect loans and
where were all the customers where were
all the businesses who now had a big
drop in their sales right I mean
restaurants I mean who was eating in
restaurants when you know everybody was
fighting a war where everybody was you
know loaning money to the government I
mean all of these businesses suffered
consumer spending imploded during the
Second World War
yet not a single business got bailed out
no no no big government relied on the
people to pay for that war now we're all
we all believe that the government needs
to bail out the people the government
needs to bail out individuals the
government has to bail out the states
the government has to bail out
corporations with what money the
government doesn't have any money it's
the people that support the government
not the other way around but we're
pretending that the government can
support the people by using a printing
press that all we have to do is print
money and nobody has to work
nobody has to produce we can have all
this stuff for free well we're about to
find out the hard way that the most
expensive way to pay for government is
through inflation through printing money
that's what we're doing and we're about
to relive the lessons of history
because a lot of countries have tried
this before and it is ended in disaster
every time it's been tried
[Music]